I looked at a bunch of influencers who
talk about Korean skincare a lot and
tried out some of the products I saw
being recommended over and over hi it's
Michelle of loudmouth and Beauty science
chemistry PhD cosmetic chemist and
person with skin Korean skincare is
obviously huge right now there are so
many products where do you start well
the internet I looked at a bunch of
influencers who talk about Korean
skincare a lot and tried out some of the
products I saw being recommended over
and over all of these are available in
Star curry in today's video sponsor
here's what I thought cosrx Advanced now
96 mucine Power Essence is probably the
first product I think of when I think
Korean skin care so many people in
skincare talk about this and the other
snail products from cos RX as well Jude
from 50 Shades of snail has been on this
now Essence train since 2015 and I think
a lot of that Reddit hype was actually
from her even now this pops up on her
Instagram at least once a month James
Welsh also always talks about cosrx
snail products in in his favorites so
this is just a really solid product that
captures a lot of the reasons that
people tend to gravitate towards Korean
skincare first off there's this focus on
hydration so East Asian skin tends to be
a bit more easily Disturbed in terms of
its Skin Barrier and there's a lot of
aircon in East Asian countries and so
that is a really good recipe for
dehydrated skin East Asian skincare
routines also tend to have a few more
steps and so there's a lot of products
that can deliver this massive punch of
hydration while staying really
lightweight and being really good to
layer with other products the products
are also usually pretty budget friendly
and there is sometimes an exotic appeal
which is definitely the case with snail
the main ingredient in this is obviously
snail mucin which is also called Snail
secretion filtrate so the logic behind
snail lessons is this goop is protecting
their belly which I know is technically
called a foot but it feels wrong to call
it a foot let's steal this group from
the snails and slap it on our skin the
most obvious thing that this immediately
does is hydrate the crap out of your
skin hydration is really the main thing
behind that glowy glass skin look and I
think that's why this product just keeps
going viral it's just really nice
instant gratification the reason it's so
good at hydrating is that snail Essence
has a really complex mix of long chain
sugary molecules called
glycosaminoglycans And proteoglycans
subscribe to my channel to hear me
pronounce long science words and these
are what gives it that really stringy
texture as well as that super hydrating
effect they're really good at holding on
to water and acting as a humectant
moisturizer aside from hydration this
product is also really known for
brightening skin tone helping with
breakouts and irritation and there's
some talk of it being good for
anti-aging and wrinkles as well it's
hard to pin any of this down to like a
single substance in the snail Essence
but it does contain a lot of
antioxidants peptides antimicrobial
compounds and even some glycolic acid
cosrix have also added some extra
ingredients that also add to their super
hydrating and soothing effect I found
that on my skin this is just amazing for
really hardcore hydration with a side of
soothing it's a very versatile product
you can apply a thick layer and even
then it isn't really sticky it's more
just hydrated and tacky you can mix a
little bit with water for a more thin
toner-like application you can mix it in
with a moisturizer and it works really
well for hydrating your skin just before
putting on makeup without leaving like a
layer that might interfere with later
products from my understanding the
process of extracting the mucin for cos
RX products doesn't hurt the snails they
crawl over textured material that
collects the mucin in a dark room and
apparently the highest quality mucin is
collected when the snails aren't
stressed snail is a natural extract
which means there is a lot of variation
and that includes the fact that the
percentage won't tell you that much
you're going to have different amounts
of the actual comp pounds within each
extract so if you're looking to try out
a snail product I would recommend
ignoring things like so-called dupes and
percentages and really just focus on
looking at reviews of individual
products also because it's a natural
extract there can be allergens in it and
there are cross reactivities between
snail and dust mites and shellfish some
people get close comadones which are
these small clogged pores that look like
flesh colored bumps but in general this
is a super popular product that works
really well for a lot of people and I
think this is a great first product if
you're just starting out with Korean
skin care the next product is the
punkang Yul Essence toner I first heard
about this brand from gothamista who is
like YouTube skincare godmother their
products are really minimalist they
focus on using plant extracts and
they're really designed for people with
sensitive skin to be honest I've kind of
been putting off testing out this brand
because I assume they were really
expensive I just thought these
ingredients don't really have a lot of
of independent verification I'm going to
have to dedicate a lot of time to
testing them out really really
thoroughly on my skin to make sure I'm
comfortable recommending something
really expensive and then I found out
that they're actually super budget
friendly they just have nice packaging
that looks expensive this Essence toner
is probably their most popular product
just from the packaging I assume this
would be around the 50 Mark it's kind of
hard to say because Style Korean are
always having different sales but right
now this smaller bottle is 5.50 USD this
has astragalus root extract as the main
ingredient it's a herb that's used in
eastern medicine there isn't a lot of
evidence for what it does on skin but
most plant extracts have some level of
humectus which will hydrate and
antioxidants that can soothe skin and
soak up free radicals this specific
extract also has betame which is
soothing and hydrating as well as
minerals the texture of this is like a
thick cushiony water that's slightly
slippery it absorbs really quickly it's
weightless and it doesn't feel tacky at
all on my skin I found that this was
really soothing and refreshing but I
wouldn't say it's really hydrating
compared to other Korean products I was
actually quite disappointed in how much
this kept my skin hydrated throughout
the day it just went away pretty quickly
it is still a lot more hydrating than
most western toners though so I think
it's really what you're looking for if
you have really dehydrated skin and you
want just one hardcore hydrating product
in your routine that keeps your skin
plump all day then this is not it but if
you want something lightweight and
soothing and your skin isn't super
thirsty if you want a hydrating toner
for summer or if you use lots of layers
of hydration if you're using like the
seven skins method then this is great
the round lab burst juice moisturizing
Sun cream has been hyped up so much it
was on both Sue Beauty and unioni's top
list of 2021 I've seen it from Bonnie
Garner of beauty alley Who does these
really comprehensive sunscreen roundups
sugar peaches loves Alice in the rabbit
hole this is also a sunscreen that's
popular with Korean customers and the
tube actually has almost no English on
it so this is like the Hipster Korean
sunscreen this is another one of those
chemical Colma sunscreens that has the
same core formula they've been super
popular over the last couple of years
and each one just has very slight
variations on a theme if you've been
watching my videos you'll know that this
family of coal my chemical sunscreens
has been top of my list for a while they
just work really well on my skin they
feel sort of like a cream gel
moisturizer going on they're really
hydrating they also just feel like they
stay on your skin pretty well they are
SPF 50 pa4 pluses which is as high as
the rating system goes in Korea they
don't leave a white cast unless you have
relatively dark skin and that white cast
probably comes from the mbbt UV filter
which is a chemical sunscreen but it's
in little particles these do leave a
little bit of a shiny finish so some
people find them quite greasy but for me
the film is just really light and it
falls on the glowy side of like the
glowy slash greasy dichotomy I think
part of that is also just that they
hydrate my skin really well which makes
my oil just feel lighter and my skin
ends up looking better rather than just
kind of gross where this falls on the
Range I found that this was slightly
heavier and richer than the beauty of
chosen sunscreen so I think this is more
suitable if your skin is drier or if
it's slightly drier weather I found this
a bit more hydrating than the isantry
one and it feels a little bit lighter
the actors in This are birth juice which
is meant to be purifying Baobab extract
and hyaluronic acid which are hydrating
Alan tone which is soothing and also the
niacinamide and adenosine which is
standard in all the chemical sunscreens
in this kind of family having all these
very similar Colma sunscreens I've seen
a dill Minard say that it's boring and I
do kind of agree but at the same time it
is also really nice to just have all
these variations on my favorite formula
if you don't like this formula or if
you're allergic to one of the components
then this is probably much less of a
good time for you but this channel is
about me the mixing Bean Essence is
another product that I heard about from
Sue Beauty she uses this as a hydrating
Essence she's raved about it so much
that I got it and started using it just
off her recommendation and then after
I've been using it for a few weeks I
looked at the product page and came
across a video by beauty within and I
found out that you can also use it as an
exfoliant sort of like a peeling gel you
can like massage it on your skin and get
skin off which I was not expecting this
was actually the top votive
multifunctional product of 2021 on glow
pick which is a Korean beauty app this
has four fermented ingredients Bean
pomegranate barley and pear that
fermented soybean explains the texture
it's really gooey and stringy and it's a
lot like snail lessons if you see natto
which is like edible Japanese soybeans
you'll know that stringiness and like
the snail lessons this texture comes
from long chain hydrating molecules that
form a sort of net over your skin that
sticks to water I'm not 100 sure what
the specific compound is but it should
be similar to natto which has
polyglutamic acid the pomegranate
extract is a natural source of alpha
hydroxy acids which provides some of
this exfoliating effect the other
extracts also have antioxidants vitamins
the standard plant extract benefits
there are a bunch of clinical studies on
this where it's smoothed out texture
helped with black hairs and also reduce
skin oil from the texture you would
expect this to be like really sticky but
it isn't it feels really nice and
hydrating on the skin and it seems to
settle down really quickly I was really
impressed by the hydrating abilities of
this I did sort of feel that hydrating
net even the next day after I woke up
for exfoliating which was is the bit I
was most interested in because I love
peeling gels you prep your skin with
warm water pump out some of the product
and just start massaging in circles then
after about a minute you start to feel
these little sand like grains on your
skin of course I wasn't entirely
satisfied with that so I pumped out more
product and the massaged it even more
and at about two minutes they were
probably about maybe 50 little grains
and these are like a little bit smaller
than really fine sand it is really
satisfying once that starts happening it
happens a lot slower than with a peeling
gel which is pretty immediate there's
also a lot less grains and I collected
some of these and looked at them under a
microscope and they looked really white
so I'm thinking most of it is actually
something in the product bunching up it
does make my skin feel super smooth and
soft afterwards more so than with a
peeling gel and I'm not sure if it's
because it is exfoliating more or if
it's just that I've been massaging this
hydrating Essence into my skin for three
minutes I do wonder if there are a lot
lot of other products on the market that
you can do this with and they just don't
promote themselves that way but I did
try it with the snail Essence as well
and I got a few tiny grains after about
three minutes of rubbing and by that
point my skin was feeling really sore
and irritated because it is a lot
stickier and yeah you're just dragging
your skin around so I do think this
Essence is like the perfect texture for
this onto some beauty I've chosen
products I've talked so much about the
beauty of chosen sunscreen but they have
a whole line of other products as well I
did give their serums a bit of a try a
while ago but my pigment and breakouts
haven't been that much of an issue so
those products didn't give me that much
benefits because they didn't Target my
skin concerns I have seen tons of raves
about them though the products I tried
for this video are the dynasty cream and
their Eye Serum with the dynasty cream
my main influencer here was Kelly
Driscoll she did a video on her top
beauty of chosen products and this was
in it she's been using this since 2015.
this was beauty of chosen's first
product and it's been through a few
reformulations since then it comes in
some really nice Luxe packaging so here
is an unboxing video this has a really
nice gel cream texture that is a little
bit on the heavier side for a gel going
on it's really lightweight and hydrating
and not at all greasy I found that this
is really good for prepping my skin
under makeup and I'm actually wearing it
under my makeup now but for my dry skin
in Winter I found that I can just use a
bit more and it still works really well
it features rice Brown ginseng and
niacinamide which are all great for
hydrating skin there's also some
smoothing and brightening effects as
well there are some really light oils in
there as well like squalane and
hydrogenated poly decking which is sort
of similar to mineral oil it also
doesn't have any fragrance which is a
bit unusual for a cream in a jar with
such sort of luxury packaging so if
you're looking for a lightweight
hydrating moisturizer especially one
that is fragrance free then this might
be a really good option I first came
across this product which is the beauty
of chosen revive Eye Serum ginseng and
rationale through Alice in the rabbit
hole she reviews a lot of Korean
skincare and beauty of chosen was
actually her favorite brand of 2021 and
this was her favorite product after I
started trying this out I also saw like
a whole flood of reviews come out
including from Dr Dre Cassandra bankson
James Welsh so maybe there is this sort
of artificial marketing push but I can't
really be mad at it beauty of chosen
have been around for so long and their
products are really nice they have
worked hard for their time in the
spotlight I'm a little bit hesitant when
I'm trying out eye creams because I wear
author K contact lenses at night and
sometimes I'll have to get out of bed
and readjust them so having greasy stuff
around my eyes can really be annoying
for that is like kind of lose grip on
the eyelid but I was really excited
about trying this one out because of the
ingredients ginseng is their star
ingredient here they say they included
it because it's been shown to Target
wrinkles it is really popular in Korean
skincare there's also rationale with an
A and this is a stronger form of vitamin
A that converts to retinoic acid
tretinoin in just one step and so it is
as close to tretinoin as you can get in
a cosmetic product so it is one step
closer than retinol with an O vitamin A
derivatives retinoids are like the gold
standard ingredients in skin care and
retinelle with an A has been making its
way into a lot of skin care products
rationale is usually encapsulated in
products and this improves the stability
of it this is really good because
retinoids are kind of notoriously
unstable there was one study that looked
at how much retinol was left in a bunch
of different products and after six
months one of them had degraded by 80
percent encapsulation also means that
the rationale gets very gradually
released onto the skin you don't just
get one massive flood at the start and
so that usually gives you less
irritation but you can still get similar
overall results sometimes I have a
little bit of doubt about some forms of
encapsulation I'm not sure it's actually
releasing all of the retinoid out of the
capsule but I don't think it's a problem
for the main form on the market which is
cyclodextrin or what's used in this
which is liposomes the rationale is that
0.02 which I think is like a nice low to
medium intensity this is one of the most
inexpensive rationale products I've seen
and of course you don't have to just use
it around your eyes on the beauty of
chosen website they actually recommend
that you can use it on the rest of your
face and on other parts of your body too
so if you're looking for like a general
rationale product to try this one is a
really good option you might want to
look out for irritation though I saw
Kelly Driscoll mentioned that she got
some irritation on her eyelid with this
which isn't that surprising because
strong retinoids do tend to make you go
a bit flaky and go through this sort of
adjustment period as your skin kind of
rebuilds itself I have a video on how to
get through that process with mineral
irritation so if this is going to be
your first rational product I highly
recommend using some of those strategies
so this was a really good batch of
products I think I might have kind of
put my thumb on the scales because I do
know what I'm looking for in products
and every time I was looking for a new
recommendation I had like a mental
checklist of what I like and I was
comparing that with what people were
saying in their reviews I think that's a
good strategy in general when you're
looking at reviews of products just make
sure you remember your actual needs and
don't just get swept Along by hype I
think the least successful product was
this Essence toner and that's just
because it doesn't really suit my style
of routine as much and even then I'm
pretty sure I'll be using this in hot
weather when I get that sort of prickly
heat feeling I hope you enjoyed chatting
skincare with me let me know what your
experiences were like with these
products don't forget to hit the like
and the subscribe to tell the YouTube
algorithm that you want to see more of
this type of content